yeah okay thank you very much one
question before hand who managed to get
to install the the environment we would
use for this so that's a few hands no
and apparently only three to four so I
intended this to be really hands-on
exercise you can try if you have content
active to just try Conda install pie
tables and netcdf for and pandas and if
you're lucky the network will hold and
give you working installation then you
can either fire up I pison or the
notebook whatever you have installed
everything should all that should work
for the beginning i'll stick with doing
live coding if you see a this is going
to slow is just boring i can switch to
the jump its version which i have
already prepared so just raise your hand
and give me a call if necessary so
starting the time
alright so my name is Thomas puff my job
description is right now is data
scientist at blue yonder before that i
would i might have called myself radar
scientist and my PhD thesis i worked
with weather radar and whenever you deal
with metrological measurements you also
have to deal with lots of data that's
where i came in contact with the
format's hdf5 and netcdf and today i
would like to present the ins and outs
of these data formats as we can use them
in python starting right away with hdf5
that format was invented basically by
yeah or is it basically is used most
prominently by NASA saving all the data
that they get from their Earth observing
satellites and basically you can
download many many products by HTF five
files directly how do you create one of
those files so fairly easy I hope this
won't work because yeah first thing you
have to do is to import pie tables and
this contrast sucks a little bit can you
can you can you see not really me
neither so I will have to talk myself
through that pie tables and because I
will produce a little bit of numpy stuff
I import number I as NP can I change the
phone I have versus expectation here
Magda
if i had a mac i would try but ice I'm
very sorry for the next talk i would get
one I thought you did have a microphone
no no no I'm a circle okay so import
tables import numpy SNP and then it
becomes fairly easy you say I want to
have a variable and I call tables dot
open underscore file with the filename
date h5 basically like the Python open
command and then there's the file mode
which can be right read our plus for
read and write a for a pen as you know
it from from standard Python and this
basically creates your file nothing in
there but you have a handle you can
write you now how to populate that as
pie the name goes high tables first
focused on using the hdf feature of
adding in homogeneous data so you can
add something like a pandas dataframe as
a table or record ray to an hdf5 why is
it called HTF hdf is short for a
hierarchical data format so in these
files you can have here okies of data
and they model that by using a unique
cilic path system so you have groups
which would relate to unix folders and
then you have the data sets that would
be would rip would be represented in a
file system as files and now we're going
to fill our file and say we want to have
a people group which is our file create
group then we have to tell pie tables or
in the hdf file where we want to have
that group so
the root level and we want to curl it
people we can also ignore the return
value and just say hf create create
group also on the root level and we call
that one data so if a file called data
at age five in that we have a folder
called people and one called data and if
I fire that the reference to that data
folder is lost if I want to recover it I
say theta is HF get node and where
should where would that node live and
how it is called and this way I get a
reference to my to my data group back so
now we have two folders in our data file
now let's fill it with data with actual
data they said one of the data sets you
can put in there as a table we can we
will talk about the other formats or
later so we have a set up a variable so
people equals hf create table we need a
little bit more space so we start where
do we want to have it we can also we can
use a string but we can also use a
reference to one of these groups we
still need to give it a name let's be
creative and call it people
and then we need to give it a
description and the easiest way is to
just give an amp ID type and you know
how that goes is a list of tuples
stating the name of that particular
column then we say the name is usually a
string of a certain length and we might
have an age which is a 2-byte integer
and we might have a height which could
be a very do bit float once we've done
that I need to get the brackets right we
also can give that a title so adding
some metadata say some tutorial
participants and if I got the brackets
right I will see in a moment apparently
yes so now we created a data object oh
that's a bit more to type so adding to
this table is fairly simple so the basic
message that I want to get across even
though these data formats I would I
would not want to look into them and I
would not want to program anything that
accesses them by myself the interface is
that the pie tables guys and the netcdf
guys has have written make eating very
very easy to access these files to work
with them bike like in memory arrays or
in-memory data append to them without
having to
to wonder to care how this stuff finds
its way to disk so getting some people
data in people that end and then we add
a list of tuples so clearly i'm a
participant of this i will even tell you
my age and my sides anything else
volunteering to give his or hers anyone
jeffrey like this CEO like this okay so
you can't lie about age 39 195 alright
so too is enough anyone else now for the
sake of speed i append them and then i
want to get them back and one of the big
advantages of pie tables compared to
other libraries is that it exposes the
object hierarchy in the file as
attributes of the object so you can say
hf rude that's the root element we have
the group people and we have the group
people and we can even get tab
completion here and then we can retrieve
with standard slicing now all elements
of our table so that should be choose
two things let's see that works so we
have what we get is return is a numpy
record array with these two entries you
see that's an integer that's that the
float converted to this strange format
and then you have these data the data
types so that's the way to access tables
and they have a fairly sophisticated
means to access these tables to do
filters on them either directly using
pythons list comprehensions or in core
so a little bit faster I don't want to
talk about those regrettably I would
like to go more into the continued
continued into the homogeneous arrays
which are I find more fascinating but
before we go there I'd like you to show
you how to add additional metadata to
those values I think most of you know
the dilemma you get a CSV file and you
have lots of data there but you have no
information where they come from well
somebody sends a document where
everything is explained every column is
explained and when it was taken and by
whom and where it came from and then
somebody asked you for data and you give
him the CSV file and you forget about
the document you explain it to them
during a during a telephone interview he
writes it down somewhere and he passes
the data on and sometimes there's just
as easily file nobody knows what's in
there with hgf files you can add the
metadata directly to the data set and
there's no way you're going to lose that
again so and adding attributes is as
easy as adding the data itself wherever
you have like for example our people
group it has a special attribute called
Viator's and there you can just add new
attributes like this one right it
doesn't exist yet but you can make it
exists
and now if you could look at that these
are a few attributes that pie table sets
for itself to make more more you are
yeah make sense of the of the data it
ceased to be more efficient and better
able to convert that thing in something
very pythonic but here's your
description attribute let's get safe to
the file and whenever you pass the data
set you pass the description with it
this was done to a folder so to say so
we can document the folder but you can
also document a data set itself guess
how you do that you say people then you
can use something that actually sounds
like attribute captions and then you say
for example they created and that is
2015 30 may 30 and then we can look at
people adders so the data set pythons
pie table saves that it's the table then
it has names name aid and hide and the
field values and so on you have the
title that you gave when instantiating
the table itself and you have the
additional version information about the
date created with pie tables you could
even even save a daytime object but if
you want to use that hdf file in with
another program or library that might
have difficulties interpreting what L
whatever pie tables saves there so if
you want to be sure you standard data
type strings floats
and so but if you're sure that you will
only work with pie tables and maybe
another pythonic Python package using
that file you may as well save any kind
of object there yeah well here it's more
like it's it's a little bit more
speaking if you look here it it
references the same attribute so you
could also save the address if you want
to say stay consistent all right so one
last thing if you lost all references
you still can get to the attributes you
have the function H get node attribute
and you even don't have to worry about
the theaters you just say people people
and then access they'd created so this
makes it also feasible to access these
attributes if you don't know during
computation type are doing coding time
how the how the attribute will be named
or and reading it from a configuration
file all right and now the interesting
stuff working with rays of homogeneous
data the hdf file format provides for
different kinds of arrays like numpy
race there's the contiguous array that
reserves the contiguous amount of memory
in the file immediately reserves that on
the on disk and lets you very
efficiently write and read from that ah
John the second one which is the most
interesting part is the chunk to raise
where the individual the whole
dimensionality of the array is
subdivided into chunks something similar
to what we heard
last morning with task array where you
to bite your data into chunks that
enables you to first compress those
making the file size much smaller and
only save those chunks we're actually
data is in so you can define a huge
array and as long as you don't write
data it to it your file stay small and
if you have a very sparse system that
might be a advantage you have an
enlarged abilities that is a super
speciality of pie tables it provides you
with one inaudible dimension hdf5
actually provides you with unlimited in
knowledgeable dimensions you just say
this is going to be a three dimensional
array but I don't know what size those
three dimensions are something that pie
numpy can't do but HTF cap and then you
can grow this array as your your data
come it comes in and finally there the
variable-length rays that are raised
that have that I don't they are not
limited to a certain size so in the
following I want to talk about the chunk
the Rays how to create one so say for
example the CA is a page f create see
array then you have to tell pie tables
where that lives we put it in the data
folder we may call it see ray we need to
give it the data type and here our pie
tables provides you with so called atoms
I'll use the float 32 Adam I swear
and in that Adam you can for example
give the default value let's say we use
NPM we need to give it a shape let's say
100 by 100 by 100 they always make a
typo here and that's basically it
chunked array million entries if you
take a look at your file system the file
has grown because we added the table
data to it but it has not grown to the
size of 4 megabytes well you would have
to ask the pie tables developers that
why they did it no regrettably not the
advantage is i think maybe they wanted
to do that because using a numpy d-type
you can't say what's the defaults going
to be so because now you have to find
that the the array you can access it if
you haven't written data there it will
return NP none or would return minus 34
if you if you told it to ya so for me
still 0 x yeah you can flush it if you
want to c hf dot flush forces it to real
to write it is
all right so where's my pointer let's
take a look at the chunk shape of this
one yeah tells me I can't create
something that I have already created we
do that like this if you don't give a
tongue shape yourself you can do that we
will do that in a moment pi tables or
hdf guesses what a good layout would be
so in here it says well most maybe you
want to save images a long time
dimension so there will be one the chunk
will be like a flat cut from that
three-dimensional q that's pretty much
what I wanted to show you what the
results are of a different junk shape
I'll define another array oh boy that's
flying a little bit by wire okay we need
to give that one a new name this as a
variable second as and then say chunk
shape
10 x 10 x 10 that might be chunk shape
more suitable if you are not sure if you
own always will look at the images or if
you want to have time series analysis as
well and that kind of data if you're
sure that you want to do time series
analysis you choose a chunk shape so
that it reads along the first time axis
or the time axis that you define okay so
let's look what that chunk array looks
like hey where are you oh my god it's
the known as boots ah so slicing a
little bit the first two dimensions are
the first two elements and then to the
fifth element you see I haven't put
anything in there so I get the default
value back but at least I get something
defined back now let's fill this create
some data that is for example non prior
random random into random numbers or 100
then if you fancy a bit of fence
indexing non plus
just in case that you wonder what all
these dark magic is that I'm doing are
you familiar with this kind of stuff all
the better so I created 100 random
numbers put them in the first dimension
and then I put 108 range arranged
numbers and added into the random
numbers over that second dimension so
here you have the random numbers here's
its incremented by one here by two here
by three so this way down is compression
level should be fairly bad and the other
way around it should be better so we
have a slight quite well compressible
random number field and now we want to
fill that interview into our file so
saying finding a function fill array
that takes an array it doesn't care
about whether it's an umpire array or
something else okay thank you for colon
and say for I in range array dot shape 0
array I comma we may fail a lot of
assumptions here but
it's just to make the point so now we
can see what what happens if we time
access to that we say time it Phil array
we pass in our car trunk to Ray and we
pass in the data and we'd go and wait a
little bit and we get hundred loops and
the best one is six milliseconds to fill
our one megabyte field to try that with
the other array it's roughly a factor
for slower because our array was aligned
the same way that the chunks were was
easy to do that in simple and very few
operations with our chunk size is a
little bit of what we in turn then we
have to pay the price that the library
has to pull in many chunks fill the data
and then pull all those chunks back so
there's a risk and the chance if you do
it wrong or if somebody says well the
safety have five stuff that is so so
horribly slow I don't want to use it
anymore maybe ask him have you chosen
the right chunk size for your problem
now no the after side before hand right
that would be the option you create a
new array with the right chunk size and
then you make a big copy operation
and now that we have filled the array we
can check if the data is right there we
say hf let's make it interactive that
route dot theta dot c array we want
everyone and the same as before and
there's our data is be as before the
random numbers in the first dimension
and the additions in the second
dimension and this is a three
dimensional array as we expected it so
next let's have a look at compression as
i said before chunking enables you to
compress your stuff so let's say for
example d u minus h of a to h5 at 7.6
megabytes right with 1 1,000,000
elements of 4 byte floats that's four
megabytes for one array and we fill two
arrays that's eight megabytes if you use
non-human readable size it gets even
closer to the eight million so how do we
add compression actually that's fairly
simple well first we open a new file
call it compressed HTF 551 say tables
open file compressed data dot H well as
cos theta1 dot h5 and we open that for
writing as well and next we say
compressed chunk array num1 equals hfc
one great see array on the root level
call it compressed use the float Adam
forgot tables not giving any default now
shape let's break it shape should be 100
500 500 as before and now because we
know that the chunk shape is going to be
good for us we say we add a filter
there's the filters glass where we can
say we want a compression level of one
for example you have a few other options
there whether you want to use a shuffle
filter whoever who joined the
Valentine's talk knows what the shuffle
filter does it reorganizes the bytes so
that the compression will can be more
effective there is a checksum filter
that you can activate
that will complain if you're the data in
your file has been corrupted and you can
also with pie table so you can choose
what kind of cone of compression
compression library you want to use here
we use the standard that's going to be
easy lib and now we create this array so
if we look at how large it is Oh giving
away a few things forgot to delete data
so this is what we created right now we
haven't written anything there and we
haven't flushed so that's 0 and now we
fill that stuff CC ray 1 and our data so
ideal chunk size factor for slower due
to the compression but if we look at the
file size now
this is 1 490 k as opposed to eight
megabytes of course that's a special
example but you can at least expect the
factor of two or something depending on
your data and depending on your chunk
size to get improvements without having
to care right we still only have access
using the numpy ish interface so
choosing a different compressor for
example can give back a little bit of
speed and here I wanted to show you what
that may may and what I'm adding here is
you can add the filters at the filters
keywords to any level of your hierarchy
so you can add it to a data set as we
did before we can add it to a folder
then all datasets below that will use
that filter unless you give explicitly
another one or you can also add it to
the file itself and then unless you say
anything else everything every data set
will be applied with this filter and for
example the comp lib we should say it's
blocks adding a new array question yeah
is there difference between the
creationist forzieri and create capital
C array if you initially five tables was
designed with these camel case letters
and with a new release they decided to
make it more pep 8 compatible so and for
time being they use both but encourage
people to use the new version
so there is one missing and then we have
to say again time it and fill the array
and our data and now we are already back
to close to where we on we were
uncompressed and looking at our disk
usage now at least a factor to you could
use have used comp level four and get
back to the to that size and still be a
reasonably fast one caveat here the
standards hdf5 library only supports
zeeland so if you want to use it outside
pi tables better stick to the standard
bloss won't be will be available for all
hdf reduce out there their jewels like
the hdf viewer provided by the hdf group
or VI tables and so on and there's no
guarantee that they have these
compression libraries available that
they were linked with us so if you want
to make sure that somebody else uses it
can use it stick with zero who of you
has been using the HTF saving feature of
Tanner's one two three four
have you looked into the file that
pandas creates you interested in how it
looks like or actually you can see for
yourself I think we have enough time
let's look let's look how these
interactions with pandas look like so
let's import pandas as P and say we want
to have 10,000 data points and we create
a data frame that consists of two
columns the one we call a and say that's
n random numbers and the other one we
call be guess what
and random numbers and now let's say the
f2 hdf call that data frame age 5 and
the 2 HD f we say data frame so the
group it should go to the group data
frame and we can say pattern DF to CSV
for example data frame dot CSV that
doesn't need anything else write it to
disk and now let's see it looks like
hfdf tables open file data frame dot h 5
now we're open for reading which we can
state and we can have a look if you just
call or if you just this the return
value of tables open file so what do we
see pandas produces a non compressed
file without any title it adds a group
data frame and in that group it adds
several data sets there's something
about X is zero that's the row labels
then there's or no that's sorry too
that's the column labels so the screen
Adam because our our color names a and B
fit into something of I of size one
it saves Italy like this as X is one
that's an array of ten ten thousand
elements length integer that's the index
and then it says I have items in block
zero and have item values in block 0 and
here it stores its data and finally it
stores all all columns of the same type
in one block so now we we added two
floating point columns so they go in one
block if we had added a string column we
did we would have two blocks one for the
floating points and one for the string
okay now I want to close this again now
want to know how much faster we can read
that stuff a PDE data frame that from
csv that took 36 milliseconds
and here we also have to give the group
so you could save more than one data
frame into into one hdf file that's
slightly faster have factor 10 so those
those who did save it was probably saved
it for that reason the other ones can do
that now too and as for size it even has
a slight advantage that's not always
true but in here it makes a perfect case
I would guess so I I'm not sure I
haven't okay yeah I would guess even
they have provided a keyword or they
would they would accept an HTF object
comp level there you go so even less
space right
I'm in the running browser window so
with that I would conclude hdf5 part and
would move on to netcdf for netcdf for
ya okay the question is where what are
the differences between pi tables at h 5
pi i wanted to do that in the end of the
talk i can do it via as well basically
pi tables project provides a more
interactive interface with the exposure
of the data set the data sets as
attributes makes it much faster to to
write all those things h 5 pi uses the
same similar interface to what netcdf is
using with ya mapping all these things
to dictionary objects that's one thing
when i used pi tables so admittedly a
couple of years ago Pylea tables was
much more mature age five pi had a few
performance problems in several cases on
the other hand h 5 PI makes a much
better does a better job or it intends
to bring as much of the hdf libraries
functionality to python so there are a
few things that pie tables just doesn't
do for example the extendable array has
only one unlimited dimension and then
you can only append step by step while
with h 5 pi you can define unlimited
unlimited dimensions and you can resize
an airy by saying well i had 10 by 10
and now i want to have it 100 by a
hundred and so you get immediately the
new space and can write more efficiently
than just a pending step by step that
would be the main features for me for h
5 pi when i checked before the talk they
have now implemented the parallel
feature of hdf5 will enable you to write
to the same file from different
processes something that you cannot do
with pi tables
yet so I think h5 Pike goes more into
the direction make it as feature
complete as possible by PI tables is
more for the ease of use and the
interactivity and maybe a bit more
performant than the other one all right
variable-length drinks not entirely sure
you would have to read the documentation
which is pretty good as most Python
documentation czar okay next year for
under the hood actually netcdf for uses
the hdf5 format but it adds a little bit
on top of that which makes some things
easier something's less easy or even
impossible and it forces you a little
bit more to document your data will see
that how that works in a minute so how
to create an SEF file well first we have
to import netcdf for you say SNC and
then we can say
nc data set basically the same syntax as
open and open file head opening it for
writing and this way we create a new
file now the first thing has netcdf
differs that see if also has groups and
data set so they it mirrors the
hierarchy of hdf but it forces you to
define so-called dimensions in HD f we
could say create me a see array of 100
by 100 by 100 effectively we will do the
same in at CDF but we have to give a
name to each of these dimensions it's
mainly used for in climate research and
there these array dimensions have a
physical meaning the mostly XY latitude
longitude time ensemble member and so on
and so netcdf forces you to create that
therefore we will have to do that to
doing the s create dimension we need to
give it a name and we start out time and
we say none and that means this
dimension is going to be unlimited let's
create another dimension call it X and
say this is going to be arbitrarily
chosen 131 elements then we create
another dimension I guess how we call it
going to be the same size
and what you see here is the deterrent
value of the last statement it returns
the reference to that dimension if you
needed further into your code that was
the adding dimensions part now there's
adding variables variables are the data
sets of netcdf and it's good practice to
create a variable of the same name for
each dimension that you have therefore
you can say for example my time
dimension each element of myarray in
this belongs to that certain time or the
X dimension gives you latitude longitude
dimension gives you the latitude and
longitude of this grid row or column and
if you do that there are tools like
grads that can read your file and
immediately work with it and display the
data and run all kinds of fancy analysis
with that if you don't do it you don't
need you but then you can't can't use
these advanced features what we now will
do we just create a data variable call
the data here we can give a numpy data
type to determine the type here's a
numpy float and then we give we need to
give the dimensions we say for example
this should be three dimensional file
time y and x coordinate i will be a
typical format for example radar images
several images stacked up on each other
so now you see here it's a net city for
variable with these dimensions the
unlimited dimensions are time so the
current shape is 0 & 1 31 1 30 14 x and
y you can give a field value if you want
as a keyword to the create variable
function so nice thing about netcdf
variables grow dynamically if you assign
to it it grows to accommodate for what
you sign so we can say first we can say
what is ok let's create an a variable
and call it time so what I said before
and I have to reuse is let's say all
variables are stored in an attribute
variables and are accessed in a
dictionary fashion and implement the
numpy interface so the variable time
depends on the dimension time that is
currently 0 let's look what the variable
data looks like we saw that already 01
31 131 now let's add some data for
example let's say eight years variables
time element 0 equals 100 that works and
if you go back and ask for the for the
shape of the variable time that you just
added to of course it has shaped one but
because that is depending on the
dimension time if that dimension has
increased it has increased in all other
variables that it belongs to so also the
variable data is now increased by one
and if you add something weird too let's
first look at the data nothing in there
so far and if we go to our example
element 5 ah that might break yeah not
defined so in here we can access because
it has the right shape we haven't
entered anything so netcdf returns the
mast array of all missing values that's
different from HTF that would return the
float array with the fill value at
missing data points netcdf presents you
the additional information there you
have entered data and there you have not
if you pass a masquerade it will honor
that and produce missing values
accordingly so now we add a little bit
data to this one now what I want saves
creature theta let's add that to an
element number 5 and all others
random numbers ah damn it ah thanks that
works so what do you guess of course
even though we didn't touch it the
dimension has changed so the shape of
this one changes and of course here
because we added data we had to increase
dimension nice feature for interactive
work bit dangerous if you do your
indexing wrong I did so preparing that
talk can quickly fill your hard disk but
basically you don't need to care about
resizing which you have to in hdf5 we're
already there yeah because in climate
modeling time is so important that CDF
provides you with few features that HTF
doesn't provide or at least our this
netcdf for library in Python provides
them to convert indices to time back and
forth to do so if you have a time
variable you and you you add attributes
the same way to do with hdf there's a
convention that you for example add an
attribute units you can do that for any
other variable but for time variable it
becomes very important because if you do
it like saying and i will need that so
often now
the same time dot units equals a string
like ours since 2015 05 30 000 000 point
zero and you add where an attribute like
calendar there are a few challenges that
you can use there's a standard calendar
there's a Gregorian calendar very
interesting read about calendars as a
Jew it you can have a julian calendar
that's good until 15 12 or something
October then there's the gregorian
calendar that is good after that or 15
days after that there's a proleptic
gregorian that is good for everything
except that it ignores the julian part
in before 15 12 and so on at least if
you give something like that the
documentation gives you what our
calendars you can give here then you
have a few nice conversion routines at
hand say for example I want to know I
want to calculate a running running
number based on this calendar
information for a certain date and so
that you can calculate it easily you say
for example
gates to numb and we added a two-time
object of 2015 5 30 12 what's what's the
time now roughly 16 o'clock and if you
give that the units and the calendar of
course you can just give the strings but
if you have an unknown and netcdf file
don't need to care but if you give the
units and the calendar then it will
calculate the number of hours since this
time um as a floating point parent and
of course there's the way back as well
which is called long today say for
example 18.3 and then timer units i am
let calendar and you get a daytime
object back so in many netcdf files the
time variable belong to the time
dimension is filled with floats like
this and with these two two functions
you can convert the floats to a daytime
object which is far more readable or if
you create one you can use the inverse
function to populate one of these time
variables in addition there is a
function called data to index where you
pass in on its to it let's say you have
a say time the first 10 elements we feel
with an a range 10 times 3 and then we
say in see page to index of a daytime
daytime object 2015 5 30 1500 this
and then you can just give the variable
time then it will calculate at what
index in your variable you will find
that particular time you can you can
configure that by default it raises an
error if it doesn't find it exactly and
you can have you have the options the
the earlier date later date or the
closest date under standard is the exact
match that was to show you how the time
variable looks like now write a 0 1 2 3
4 5 that's 15 o'clock I've we asked for
so that's very nice if you want if you
have to work with x here's a lot now
thinking about no index calculations by
yourself just using these functions the
next cool thing about netcdf that it
allows you h 5 pi might allow you to
basically the HTF library enables it is
multi file access so as an example i
have downloaded from the American
National Weather Service a data set of
radar data that's the radar in Oklahoma
the year two thousand five and I well I
created those 12 months data files but
that's fairly fairly often the case that
you get data files for a certain period
of time because the whole thing would be
just too large it's just much easier to
manage in smaller chunks and now the
multi file interface allows you to
read all those files as one large fun
without having to care and exercise and
doing that is very easy there's an MF
data set where you just pass basically a
wild card expression and it looks for
all those files and pulls them together
now what can you what can you do that of
course you can see what variables are in
there
so apparently there's a pressie para
underscore zero variable that contains
our data there's x and y coordinate and
there is a time coordinate and along
that it looks when it does that multi
file concatenation first it gets the
ones in sorted order then it looks for
first unlimited dimension it finds and
then it concatenates all the arrays
along that dimensions it's read-only
unfortunately so we can only do read
operations there just five more minutes
okay my watch says I'm 111 so I have 20
more minutes but it's okay I show you
the cool stuff and then we stop it there
so let's look at the time variable
for example what are the units I made
those up so it starts at two thousand
five 11 the point what I want to make is
who remembers what happened in 2005 in
Oklahoma pardon maybe there was a
bombing would you see that on the
weather radar okay as the year of
Hurricane Katrina that one made its
landfall according to wikipedia on
august 29 and so you would of course you
can open just the a the august data file
but now way that we have the multi file
data set we can for example look at the
index
lets say 28 five o'clock in the evening
there's a missing in 2005 yeah okay and
what is that index I actually I don't
care what that enix means I got this
from there from Jake vanden plas an
animation example and what I'm doing now
is I'm accessing the variable principal
ray based on this index for a couple of
frames so I have 350 frames here and it
starts with frame 0 and it loads the
data from the file and it walks up and I
hope that the beam that the
infrastructure here doesn't kill me now
they are say hello to Katrina
approaching the radar say hello to
Katrina's I few data sets missing and
there she goes and while this will
repeat endlessly so that's what you can
do with a multi-fight agent said without
caring whether you walk across a month
border or your border to use it to make
that point a bit more pressing I can say
underscore zero and I can retrieve all
data for a certain point damn
now I'm a true I'm truly broken there I
did it again this is code 80 for example
86th I don't know where what there is
but i can calculate the mean over it all
the data over all the files without
having to care of course this pulls that
stuff into memory so you can't pull the
whole thing in well you can try if your
computer is large enough you can try but
whenever you do slicing operation it
pulls that slice into memory but at
least you don't need to worry about the
the other stuff so with this I would
come to a close my summary a bit i did
before so pi tables is very mature very
efficient in my opinion it's great for
interactive work it's very flexible by
virtue of the flexibility of the hdf5
and but it doesn't implement all
features that the library implements
that their 85 pie maker does a much
better job netcdf has a smaller api
smaller set of things that you can do
but that it does well it puts a bit more
restrictions on what what you have to do
in addition to justifying your data set
but it enforces more metadata which is
not a bad thing by itself it has very
convenient time handling and multi file
interface and therefore is also
practical beyond that is just another
layer over 85
you can google them yourself big thank
you to Damian Avila for doing that rise
presentation stuff that you can put
notebooks into something very useful I
think very presentable and if we have
questions questions if not thank you for
your attention hope you enjoy working
with those state of data formats thanks
you